ouais
ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais
dans ces grands chez canaccord ce soir
ça va
[Musique]
ok
l'été rêvé par daniel schick écoutant le
temps à la télé une expérience est
d'abord c'est très agréable d'être
harcelés ou donc j'étais harcelé par une
femme s'appelle dominique cantien way
avoir goût non je ne bois jamais excuse
moi tu bois jamais jamais c'est du
champagne
ouais et non je bois de l'eau evian
fuite et pommes cassis quand t'es jamais
lu de champagne non s'il avait on m'en
propose mais j'aime pas non franchement
il alcool en général ça te fait quoi
quand on boit mais j'en sais rien parce
que j'ai encore essayé buy-side tient
non j'ai pas envie je me sens mal je lui
m'abandonner non je veux bien mais si
ces trois verges dans ses attendus que
je bois ouais oui tu veux de goodwood
qu'est-ce que non mais c'est du vrai
scandale
je trouve ça épouvantable avant c'est la
meilleure drogue
peut-être mais c'est peut-être ça dont
j'ai peur c'est que ce soit une drogue
ça me viennent tu as perdu tu abandonné
où je pense pas que non je pense que
quand tu t'abandonnes c'est pas
l'extérieur qui peut le provoquer certes
la drogue le pétard pariot l'alcool
c'est un faux abandon c'est une
destruction mais ce n'est pas un abandon
l'abandon c'est s'oublier essayer de
l'oublier mais j'ai beaucoup de mal mais
alors fais partie des gens qui a vendu
on a du mal à oublier
cela dit moi est ce que ta mère adorée
d'abord ma mère était un cargo elle n'a
pas vu elle n'a pas vu non
elle était en voyage sur un bateau avec
mon papa a campé sur sa que l'audience a
pas été pris dans ces dernières a pas
fait la pub dans le quartier ça ne peut
pas marcher et non la télé steve il faut
que les parents restent la pub dans le
quartier non ça va pas marcher vite leur
quartier et efficace et tous les
quartiers d'été était sur un bateau
morin
oui
issoufou
[Musique]
et toi
suffit beaucoup c'est une drogue
dangereuse avant surtout pour celui qui
aime pas la publier de cigarettes se
dérange que je fais oui mais je sais que
tu es mal élevé que si je te demande
d'arrêter tous les profits mais voilà
mêmes
[Musique]
mon coeur qu'ils sont
fin
je suis
et toi
tous
qu'est ce que tu sais faire alors à
correctement que maintenant alors que
faire alors je préfère par exemple voilà
non mais c'est pas peur pour ton planche
et je peux te faire un deux trois j'ai
bull et donc mes cinq a déjà en voilà un
truc que je ne sais pas faire à nous il
ya beaucoup de choses que tu sais pas
faire je peux dire
thierry jeté dans la cour à l'envi
n'importe quoi mais je peux chanter mais
je peux surtout poser des questions donc
tu sais danser chanter poser des
questions et tu vas te demander ton posé
une question maintenant évidemment
[Musique]
mon coeur qui souffre
faux
j
et toi
[Musique]
c'est
est ce que tu penses que l'interview
nous devons nous voulons faire a été
sincère est ce qu'elle a été original ce
qu'elle n'a pas été facile et démago est
ce que si on avait envie de la refaire
tu dirais si on pouvait leur faire te
dirai où il vaut mieux la refaire non je
pense que ce n'est pas une interview moi
j'ai fait beaucoup d'interviews
quand je faisais des unités à vue je
faisais pas comme ça c'est pas une case
aussi une conversation donc pour une
conversation ça va il pour une interview
tu aurais voulu quoi savoir à quel âge
tu défends reculé pour la première fois
ça m'est pas encore arrivé
[Musique]
la voilà
[Applaudissements]
à
c'est à moto c'est pas moi non je suis
avec victor emmanuel c'est mon vélo et
au jeu les cacher pourquoi comble vol ce
qu'on en a déjà volé 2 alors oui c'est
intéressant ce qu'on se dit c'est
parfait non non ça va ces contrées bien
je te défonce des lois qu'ils n'ont pas
renoncé à bane un gars que je viens de
te revoir peut-être oui oui mais c'est
d'avoir une vraie interview on va manger
voix de bart aux là tu veux pas venir
non chassés déjà pris j'ai baissé comme
une cité tous bords se sera cérébrale
parties cérébrales
donc ça peut pas je t'invite pas
j'ai un gros problème mon cher thierry
je suis un garçon curieux mais je suis
un garçon qui a peur
ouais donc j'aimerais savoir ce que
c'est que la drogue mais j'ose par mme
groguhé j'aimerais savoir ce que c'est
que ces lieux de débauche nocture et
puis je n'ose pas y aller mais je me dis
que j'ai encore jeune et que j'aurai le
temps de venir et l'acheter à quand un
an entièrement refait à tonnage moi
j'étais alors j'ai pas content non j'ai
beaucoup plus que ça mais j'espère que
ça se voie pas se voit pas trop merci
match nul chez le même chargeur
sauf que toi ils ont raté le bus qui
casse toi qu'est-ce 3 on va continuer
dans un air canard
[Musique]
lamy
m
on écrit pendant sa tournée qui le lie
au moment des faits est situé au niveau
sorties et les montées maison à la bombe
en train de filmer la scène
il est mort alors qu'il est monté bisous
qua non ils sortent du temps il a du
boulot fille alors en vo un immeuble où
michel drucker non diagramme la roma
dame
au modem on nous attaque aurait beau
chalet sont pas du bruit
baghdad témoin
il a pas
temps
non
non non
m
oui
[Musique]
je
ça va ça va la voiture
si tu manges suit derrière
c'est un tout petit peu les choses mais
quand même très bonne sur bonnet j est
arrivé
je pars pour camions ils sont arrivés
comment d'ailleurs et les huit pardon
elles sont arrivées comment
ça sera ouvert dès la semaine prochaine
c'est pour toi ce champagne
oui tombe un peu se sent prêt
c'est quoi
vous êtes féru d'émissions radio voir ce
qu'il faut voir tout de suite fait des
démonstrations
c'est une mère rêve sur papier bible
alors là à huy
ah oui là à battants stores est tout de
suite dans la nuit puis fille tu dis tu
parles tu vas tu
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça ces
écrivains qui veulent parler
attention ces délicieuses non c'est
magnifique c'est mal vu de parler de cul
c'est marrant attention attention
messieurs ici le ne parlons pas
seulement du ce mot que vous n'êtes
prononcé c'est un ensemble
ces sables
mal vu de parler du marquis
alors ils font recommandé d' espaces ce
merveilleux servi de ce petit bible à
tous
l'idée c'est bien cela parce qu'on m'a
dit ça se passe bien
ils disent la pléiade c'est chiant et me
disent tu n'arrêtes pas non mais je le
veux mais tu le veux mais dis donc dire
que je suis en train de travailler dans
des catalogues pirelli surtout le texte
ouais tension qu'est ce qu'il a dit de
mieux saad
si tu devais garder mes chiottes non pas
une phrase mais où seul vous solide et
de ça tu sais quoi
je vais bien je voulais expliquer sa de
jeunes générations je veux bien
accomplir tous les clips
en satisfaire mes passions mais jamais
aucun crime pour satisfaire les passions
des horaires
qu'est ce que c'est en gros ça va
vraiment vous savez en gros c'est ça
on savoir si l'athéisme a besoin de
martyrs mon sens est prêt
ça va alors ça va plutôt se livrent ces
marches sur vivant denon lecavalier
ça marche
ça se tend
ouais
la période est excellente
parce que les faux livres
on sent
pris dans la tourmente les vrais en
tendance sur le se détacher c'est dur
d'être actualisé notre époque
non non
sacha gagne pas beaucoup quoi
c'est pas un jugement de valeur
d'abord ça gagne pas si mal et puis
ensuite on le fait pas pour ça on ne
fait rien on le fait pour être libre et
franchement est ce qu'il ya une position
intéressante
aujourd'hui on se montrent que pour
boire vivre avec ça et du papier
c'est à dire c'est bien franchement
quand même mais c'est bien ça veut dire
quoi être seul sauf à se retrouver tous
les métiers
c'est un peu ingrat commun aurait tout
seul quelle merveille ailleurs
c'est tout avec les autres de composer
désormais moi ce matin
tous les matins je suis seul voilà
sûrement 3,4
le choix revient à manger les 8
j'étais encore voilà comment on trouve à
la fois d'aujourd'hui
c'est bizarre y at il un pilote dans
l'avion
y at il un avion y at il des gens
réveiller parce qu'aujourd'hui la france
sérieux je veux dire je crois pas que
c'est devenu la zone française de
l'europe et finalement nous on a eu bien
nourris chaleur je m'en suis toujours
fait une charte est vive et ouais non
pas encore 1 c'est à toi suivant
pour à l'esprit bras
moi j'aimerais bien y croire eh ben
j'aime voir plus souvent que la france
existe encore tranché le banc
puisque je suis là wen en mai encore oui
non et encore une dizaine de personnes
nous tiraient alors
hélas leur organe a disparu
[Musique]
ce qui a été
il faut lire heideger tuées par balles
allez des guerres je suis dans l'impasse
l'istat c'est très clair
et on peut le dire à la télévision
entre le passé
et ce qui a été
le passé ça c'est dans lequel tu sembles
temps google
péniblement pour trouver que tout ça n'a
plus aucun intérêt le passé est le passé
il revient pas c'est un débat il en
tombe en le faisant il traite son site
web
passer une fois par année
en revanche ce qui a été continue d'être
c'est à toi de choisir si tu es digne de
ce qui a été ici qui n'en est pas tout
situent dans des paquets si tu n'en es
pas tu n'es pas capable de porter ce qui
a été et qui continuent d'être à travers
toi tu peux combattre la plus recherchée
qui connaît la dichotomie entre le passé
ce qui a été intéressant vous jamais
entendu ça avant tu vois donc ce qui a
été et continue d'être sa toile de
savoir si tu veux être ni anti g dans le
passé ou être à la mesure de ce dakar
mon pote
j'ai appris un truc et les gonzesses
alors qu'est ce qu'elle pense de toi de
très jeunes filles comme ça j'ai pas non
plus que j'ai kitsch et
ça m'intéresse pas c'est rachel pensent
de moi je crois là pour ça ce qui
m'intéresse pas elle-même qu'elle me
raconte des histoires ce que pensent de
leur mère argent c'est très intéressant
nous interrogeons sur la mer
et puis au fond en rester là c est clair
je crois aussi à faire ce soir
là maintenant
j'aimerais de pathos
non pourquoi dans la une
parce que je me dis qu'à
je vais dans les boîtes je regardais les
gens dansaient sais où je vais aller
voir mes études d'ascenseur beaucoup
énormément de bien
j'ai fait ça mais c'est cher
tu viens pas quoi je fais ça quand
j'étais jeune qui me permettait
j'étais bien jeune a finalement
non mais oui mon frère tariq pourtant
quand on peut déclencher les appétits
partie sa petit amie muriel
[Musique]
il décide
ayew
m
ça
[Musique]
cherchez les tétines noir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
et
[Rires]
[Musique]
je suis noir
or j'avais comme ça ces nouvelles
histoires
puisque groupe existe depuis assez
longtemps
encore un autre ajoute au départ
pourquoi un jeu de mots un peu sur
l'enfance et de dérision de l'enfance
comme des tétines noir un peu sont un
peu morbide
ouais un peu morbide a ainsi peu ça
théâtre un peu cruel ouais
c'est que vous inspirent les plus je
crois que c'est plein de gens assez
différent ça va se plaignent de la
musique ça peut être des des films des
jeux les plasticiens c'est le bruit des
oiseaux ou châtains c'est un peu on est
toujours un peu à l'écouté ont transcrit
ça après une sorte de filtre moulinette
les détériore les gens qui sont lassés
des femmes
c
[Musique]
très peu
et
m
mais
[Musique]
entendu parler mais cet appareil nous
butons paris six mois c'est moi de
donner ses six mois comme messi moins
qu'ammann six mois comme vous fait quoi
de pas grand chose
vous peignez même pas écrire et je
n'écris pas donc je n'écris pas là bas
je vois les flamands roses passer à
l'est
[Musique]
et
wahaha
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ah oui
hélas
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est pour ce magazine que tu avais blur
non ça c'est pour le magazine pour
lequel je bossais avant c'était le
couple
le magazine concurrents s'appellent b
mag ah bon ouais je le redis écouter
qu'est ce qui peut vous faire rire parce
que vraiment j'en sais ma première
couverture il faut quelque chose là
parce que ça va pas la tronche comme ça
ça va pas du tout et puis il disait
shoah sur titres j'avais un petit tee
shirt comme ça je me dis que j'ai
peut-être pas leur montrer les alger
juste soulevé le t-shirt si vous très
beau décolleté continuant leurs bras et
que la laïcité contre et et ça ça ça
m'arrive de montrer mon décolleté quoi
mais sans
dans l'intimité un ça va
wade et bohain ouais ça va ça va non
mais c'est cool je m'en sors je vais
encore il n'ya pas trop d'espacé jouanny
malien la ccrc bon ouais c'est vrai bon
tu fait pour ça et à part ça je fais je
fais quoi
je fais des photos j'ai une rubrique sur
la nuit et
donc ça me plait quoi jamais je vais
dans les boîtes dans les bars je vais je
vais au queen au palace les boîtes
classique chedjou est parfois dans ce
n'est pas bon cd non bidon et je sais
que c'est ma accru les attaques lancées
les boîtes un peu partout dans sa
peluche pas du tout quel [ __ ]
j'en ai entendu parler vite senti j'y
suis jamais allé j'en ai entendu parler
j'en ai entendu parler j'en ai entendu
parler j'y suis jamais allé ouais je te
jure je suis jamais à temps j'étais
assez peu par curiosité j'aimerais
j'aimerais aller voir par curiosité on
connaît pourquoi pas pour aller voir
pour aller voir rien tu déconne pas j'ai
pas du tout envie de faire quelque chose
quoi a priori jda avait certes été comme
ça tu commences pas
à me laisser aller comme nom moi je dis
non non non je serais très très réglos
pièce qui met ce qu'ils vont accepter
dans cette tenue quoi je pense qu'il ya
de bonnes raisons non tu veux tu les
schismes pourquoi parce que j'ai été
dans une fin j'ai essayé d'aller dans
une voiture à partouche et puis comment
elle s'appelait le 2 + 2 voila voila et
je suis rentré j'avais une robe petite
robe à trous avec juste un petit string
en dessous et tout est là un homme dit
non non c'est pas possible pourquoi ben
judy m'écouter madame pour pourquoi
enfin je l'aï écouté la prochaine fois
bon vous pouvez revenir à une tenue
correcte est exigée s'il vous plaît si
vous habillez faut d'abord s'habiller
voilà bah c'est assez logique
oui non mais pourquoi pas sexuellement
comment s'appelle sexuellement comment
ça se voit ça se passe assez bien tu es
content ya des hauts et des bas en ce
moment ça va tranquille
ces eaux
je cherchais un jules qui adorable
l'espace d'un mois non il est super
d'orange
le bonheur est dans le pré court j'ai
dit qu'on évite le bonheur est dans le
pré visite il va filer si tu veux le
rattrape et courges évident pour des
vitres qui tu veux rattraper très vite
ils vaccinés dont l'entrée de certains
des cours et des poursuites dont là
c'est le serpent les cours y vite il
veut filer sur les cornes de béliers
communiste que vous dites sur les cornes
de béliers courrier vite il va finir sur
le flou du sous sol est gorgé vie courez
vite sur le flanc du sursaut lait qu'on
va vite il va si les deux premiers en
seriez vous avez vous évite de pommiers
cerisiers que vous y vite il va filer
son ombre par dessus des corps si vite
très vite sautent par dessus des cours
les vite ils innovent fils
comment ça va stéphanie vient ici
bonsoir j'ai pas envie d'être à paris
mais voilà en stéphanie alors je vais te
dire un truc stéphanie aussi je veux
qu'elles viennent avec nous stéphanie ne
connais pas du tout ce genre d'endroit
garde à vous quand même pas la dernière
enfin je suis sûr que c'est un modèle
c'est pas la dernière non plus un
changeait rien mais fait du bien à mon
petit tu va bien et vous serez en bas
tout va bien on va en bas
tu vois stéphanie les gens sont bas
champs sont pas nues
voilà bientôt connaître gauche c'est pas
mal
[Musique]
discret jolie petite coupe de champagne
une petite coupe de champagne par
exemple on peut avoir deux coupes de
champagne complet jamais déçu samedi
bout elles seront alors que vous êtes
venu tout en chantant qui vous même qui
avez décidé je suis venu m'entraîner
très variés nord n'a pas évolué c'est
toujours pareil final et alors on dit
que c'est pareil y'a des hackers les
spectateurs pas une petite visite
je lance alors des douze frédéric on va
les voir
j'ai entendu parler d'un truc absolument
c'est ça mon nom au japon paraît-il
j'ai juste un truc pour mettre la [ __ ]
du mec comme et le tipi tirera sans voir
même mot c'est un beau c'est limite j'en
ai un bras façon dont le braille chose
pour pompey message ici c'est pareil les
gens ici on met le bras
par contre c'est la journée du mais faut
rentrer dedans physiquement en train de
dire oui je comprends pas voilà
boîte ça tu peux y aller pour deux par
derrière si tu fais le coma il est ce
que tu veux moi je comprends pas comment
ça marche
allez le seul avantage de 10 h
ce que j'aime bien et l'originalité de
cette loi finalement c'est à dire aucun
solvant dedans tant qu'à faire une
faveur en ce qui me concerne
ensuite tu peux passer les mains et pas
le palper ailleurs ce que tu veux
imagine que quelqu'un une personne place
à une autre personne
c'est concret on passe la main s'est
estompé et celui-là tu fais tu laisses
faire tes doigts
[Musique]
c'est à dire que tu peux tomber à
l'extérieur sur une fille c'est
stéphanie d'avoir un type qui touche à
nice et pas du tout ce que tu penses et
enfin entier pas qu'ils touchaient vanik
toi tu pensais qu'en fait c'était un
endroit où il avec une des choses qui
sortaient en fait c'est pas du tout le
même principe
c'est une chose tu rentres dedans voilà
voilà voilà
c'est génial elle peut sortir des morts
qui veut aussi sortir la main voilà
regarde mais sexy dance et des boîtes
d'amour pas si gentil que c'est
magnifique
ils sont quand tu fais rentrer et à
mascate extraordinaire au niveau du
fantasme c'est à dire
un homme peut plaire à une femme il va
la toucher et il va mal la caresser
alors qu'elle quelqu'un qui peut à coup
ne pouvaient pas physiquement mais quand
je pars contre le règlement
bien lancé par l'homme ne sait pas qui
de dents et la fin de ces paquets dehors
tu voulais bien ce sera moi toi c'est à
dire qu'on va laisser faire par contre
si tu rentres dans la boîte je veux bien
sais pas il faut être moderne c'est quoi
c'est ça devant ce soit propre
[Musique]
tu crois que tu vas te plaire ici
stéphane est ce que tu veut habiter là
maintenant tu vas passer quinze jours
ici donc j'espère que ça va être clair
en la salle de punition stéphanie
question pensent qu'elle ait livré au
bon plaisir d'une trentaine de personnes
sympas on s'y fait très bien
on sait très très sympa il fait frais on
peut expérimenter fait pas bon on aura
plus d'essence ah bon
m
[Musique]
c
nous sommes les marseillais nous sommes
les marseillais et nous allons gagner
ban
au bal de la nuit cuire à mon petit tu
sers à côté au bal de la nuit
on parle du neo
pire à mon enfant sera content
d'être de temps
au bal de la rue
comme halle du château
ge sera vendu
tu répartira
une balle des années la fête terminée
tu seras pas du parc des jalles dit
des longs cheveux blonds or en fait faux
bond au bal moribonde tout sera fait aux
bleus mais cela je m'en vais je pars la
comédie oui oui prochaine un store in
store in store
[Musique]
à
c'est bien comme à bas taux
dambach en dodon
l'eau c'est ça c'est bien sur les murs
non labellisés de cette galerie oui ça
me vient de rire on appelle ça il ya un
an six ans cette fois elle est très peu
connue en fait dans le monde de
l'architecturé mais très connu un bond
de la peinture parce que verdi bailly
c'est un dé lui même est un des plus
grands experts d'art d'art classique
j'ai toujours eu envie d'aller dans les
musées la nuit moi je trouve ça m'a
amusé mais sa boîte
[Musique]
gd
m
l'écouté dockers ont montré leur
à
[Applaudissements]
ouah
alors qu'est ce qui se passe avec ce
stade et le grand stade
ouais il va se construire il doit taper
un projet qui a été refusée toi tu
attaques et c'est ça j'ai fait un projet
qui a été choisie par un jury qui a été
refusé sur les critères qui n'avait rien
à voir ni avec l' architecture ni avec
les données objectives d'un contrat de
concession
j'ai attaqué au niveau du tribunal
administratif mais enfin le tribunal
administratif
on sait ce que c'est en france c'est du
simple un peu délicate on me le dire
comme ça et le haut niveau que l'on
européen puisque le marché européen la
commission européenne s'est intéressé au
sujet et je pense que la première phase
d'instruction contre l'état j'utilise
anomalie qui avaient été constatés et
tout ça devrait se terminer face à la
cour de luxembourg
oui mais comme ci comme ça doit être
fini pour 98 même s'il donne raison
c'est bien qu'il ya un problème d'un vin
d'honneur et d'honneurs d'honneur si je
me suis battu sur cette histoire c'est
pas pouvoir bien concours de plus jamais
plaint du prochain de son c'est parce
que les conditions étaient
insupportables
l' architecture ne peut pas servir
d'alibi à des tractations politiques ou
financières de ce niveau là à quoi sert
la même volonté
au niveau des monuments que mitterrand
de laisser derrière lui vise les droits
que c'est pas automatiquement sa
vocation mais il faut se rappeler que ce
n'est pas la vocation mitterrand non
plus quand il construisit dans la nièvre
y construisait une construction assez
mièvre et puis dès qu'il est devenu
président il a été entouré des
conseillers qui ont fait quand même que
ce qu'il a fait de mieux mitterrand pour
toi comme comme grands monuments
je crois que ce qui a été le plus
important dans l'atelier du terran c'est
le fait de décréter que la modernité
pouvaient être assumés entièrement
architecturaux par l'état et à partir de
là on a vu les grands projets mais ce
qui est plus important que les grands
projets c'est ce que ça c'est une idée
des grands projets à travers la
décentralisation beaucoup de mairies ont
fait la même chose et à travers les
grands projets il ya quand même des
choses qui sommes si tu devais faire un
top five tu dirais quoi en premier jeu
pas moins de pyramide la grande arche
je crois que c'est très difficile à dire
mais je
d'abord je me mettrai en jeu ça va de
soi
mais je crois que le parc de la villette
devenir quelque chose de beaucoup plus
important que le croyais et je crois que
ça évolue très bien je crois que la vue
de nuit est super mais ce serait
d'ailleurs là un bon support pour une
émission de télévision faut je trouve
que l'arche remplit parfaitement son
rôle au niveau du challenge bell
inspecté oui je trouve que l'aménagement
pyramide et on a une vertu énorme c'est
de continuer le louvre qui est une
concrétion permanente et j'espère qu'au
xxième siècle nous rajouterons encore
quelque chose ils continueront tout ça
donc je crois que l'iliade et des
actions qui au niveau de la la
concrétion de la ville sans vraiment
positive est ce qu'il a fait de plus les
ce qui a fait reculer
c'est un jeu pour moi c'est pas une
question de laideur c'est une question
peut-être mais les biens laissés par
exemple pertinent la tourment pendant je
pense que c'est le grand paris non je
pense que c'est l'opéra de la bastille
qui est le plus raté avec toi si demain
matin tu passais sous un camion
qu'est-ce que tu te sens tu vas se passe
plus important on sait jamais on sait
jamais mais
ce qui est plus important c'est que les
bâtiments soient aimés alors que moi je
les aime ne prouve pas qu'il soit aimé
par les autres moi je crois que ce qui a
peut-être ce qui est peut-être le plus
important c'est la fondation cartier
c'est nemausus ces deux programmes
complètement opposées mais c'est comme
ça màj ces logements sociaux que sont
les mêmes ils sont une autre façon de
concevoir le logement pour ceux qui
n'ont pas trop les moyens qui sont ni
vraiment très grand très ouvert et de
grandes terrasses avec des matériaux
industriels
je pense aussi que ce que je suis en
train faire à lucerne par exemple est
très important centre culturel qui est
dans un site extraordinaire parce que la
ville de lucerne est une prodigieuse au
plan de l'architecturé du paysage et les
montagnes le lac est juste à l'entrée du
lac dans la ville je fais le
l'auditorium pour le festival en termes
de 2000 places le musée d'art
contemporain un théâtre enfin un très
gros intrigue au complexe culturel qui
marquera la ville et l'institut du monde
arabe je pense et ce qui aimait y est
dans une phase difficile parce qu'ils
n'ont pas les moyens de l'entretenir et
ça me fait un peu souffrir de visiter
une voiture en fait pratiquement les
deux tiers comme activité à l'étranger à
90% actuellement le seul programme
important que j'aie en france c'est le
palais de justice de nantes que j'ai
gagné dans un concours il ya deux ans et
je fais des petites choses en
particulier l'extension d'une maison de
vieilles personnes qui est à rueil
malmaison et que d'un programme qui est
petit mais qui me passionne et quand
même architecte de ton niveau dans le
monde à peu près une dizaine je pense
que ça veut dire mais disons que il y en
a qui s'amusent à faire chaque année ce
qu'on appelle le le top ten je suis là
et c'était depuis quelques années dans
le top ten voilà c'est bien
et si tu t'habilles pas si tu t'es pas
bien en noir uniquement pour me faire
plaisir
comme tu me connais depuis plus de dix
ans je sais que tu connais la réponse
[Musique]
mais voilà
non
là
ou pas
[Musique]
m
waouh
[Musique]
by one
ok
m
et
[Applaudissements]
tiens
m
votez
et
oui je
j'espère
tchèque
oui
non
m
du jamais vu
[Musique]
chanter
je
[Musique]
tiens
javaux
[Musique]
à
oui
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
le lean a l'habitude abonnez vous y
mettez un peu de bleu